suite on va plus loin dans paris direct
[Musique]
on va plus loin ce soir avec corentin
peinard guerre journaliste à l'express
spécialiste de l'europe bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous et également avec moi
virginie herz chroniqueuse
internationale à france 24 bonsoir
virginie on va revenir ce soir sur cette
crise ukrainienne et cette intense
ballet diplomatique depuis le début de
la semaine après la russie hier lundi et
l'ukraine tout à l'heure emmanuel macron
était ce soir à berlin où il a rencontré
le chancelier allemand olaf scholz et le
président polonais duda ils se sont
montrés unis pour préserver la paix en
europe unie pour tenter d'éviter un
conflit armé alors que moscou a massé
depuis des semaines des milliers de
troupes à la frontière ukrainienne on va
écouter est tout de suite emmanuel
macron le président français nous aurons
à poursuivre dans les prochains jours et
les prochaines semaines dans le cadre du
format normande et des échanges qui sont
le cadre politique du règlement de la
crise russo ukrainienne
le réengagement de ce dialogue et la
prise de responsabilité de tous les
partenaires tels que cela était confirmé
publiquement par les président poutine
et zemlinsky est le seul chemin qui
rendra possible la paix en ukraine et à
ce titre ce réengagement est une étape
importante pour que nous puissions
poursuivre nos travaux et de l'autre
côté il y a un travail qui est menée par
l'otan par les états unis d'amérique par
nous aussi en tant qu'allié et en tant
qu'européens pour bâtir les éléments de
garanties de sécurité les derniers jours
ont permis de faire émerger des pistes
nouvelles nous allons ensemble du
travail et
virginie herz se sont coincées piste
dont parle emmanuel macron alors on sait
pas dans le détail exactement ce que
sont ces pistes en tout cas ce qui est
ce que le président français voulaient
c'est qu'on revienne aux accords de
minsk 2 de 2015 et qu'on essaye de les
appliquer alors ça fait déjà maintenant
plusieurs années qu'on essaie de les
appliquer le problème on sait que en
principe ces accords suppose que qu'il
ait des élections dans les deux
républiques séparatistes de l'est de
l'ukraine avec donc au préalable une
modification de la constitution ukraine
n pour permettre plus d'autonomie et
préalablement un désarmement total et
c'est là dessus que ça achoppe c'est à
dire que la façon dont la chronologie où
le séquençage comme on dit
les différents acteurs ne sont pas
d'accord les russes d'un côté les
ukrainiens de l'autre et c'est là dessus
que les diplomates vont devoir vent
devoir travailler corentin bénard guerre
ces accords de minsk ils sont la clé en
tout cas c'est le format sur lequel
emmanuel macron et les européens veulent
travailler on sait que ça donne un vrai
une vraie légitimité aux allemands et
aux français pour discuter à la fois il
a réussi avec l'ukraine ça permet à tout
le monde de se réunir autour d'une table
ce sera le cas jeudi à berlin on aura
les conseillers diplomatiques ukrainien
des consignes du clos matic russe
soutenue par la france et l'allemagne
donc ça donne un cadre de dialogue et
c'est une clé pour avancer en tout cas
parce que tant qu on dialogue on était
balaguer
virginie herz emmanuel macron olaf
scholz et le président polonais tout à
l'heure ils se sont montrés unis ils ont
dit vouloir être unis pour préserver la
paix en europe c'était important cette
séquence pour les européens ce soir
visiblement en tout cas pour eux c'était
important de l'affiché d'ailleurs je
vois que c'était aux la chose de
chancelier qui a fait remarquer qu' il
n'était pas là en seulement en tant que
chefs d'état et de gouvernement ou
chancelier mais également parce qu'il
présidait trois organisations
européennes en internationale en ce
moment à savoir louer 6e pour la pologne
l'union européenne pour la france et le
g7 pour l'allemagne et qu'ils allaient
essayer à ce titre là aussi de faire
exister
l'europe dans ce set crise dans laquelle
en fait on voit bien que poutine essaye
d'abord et avant tout d'établir un
dialogue bilatéral avec les russes dans
l'optique de parler d'égal à égal et de
rétablir une certaine forme de puissance
donc le premier objectif c'est de dire
non nous l'europe on veut aussi avoir
notre mot à dire dans cette crise qui
concerne la sécurité européenne donc on
ne peut pas nous mettre de côté comme à
essayer de faire la lumière poutine
depuis le début et ensuite on sait très
bien que les acteurs enfin les
différents pays européens ont des
sensibilités différentes
et que la pologne notamment est beaucoup
plus
craintive ou craint beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus alerte aux risques aux
risques russe que ne le sont les
allemands qui eux sont sous dix ans la
pression d'intérêts économiques avec le
avec north stream 2 mais là ils ont
quand même parler d'une seule voix en
tout cas ils ont tous dit nous nous
voulons éviter la guerre en europe
première chose et il ya deux principes
auxquels nous tenons c'est l'intégrité
territoriale et la souveraineté
parce que cette unité des européens
n'était pas forcément gagné au début un
côté allemand notamment dans la
coalition il y avait quelques réticences
à la réponse enfin c'est la réponse à
donner à la russie n'était pas forcément
la même mais c'est une grande surprise
je pense d'ailleurs pour vladimir
poutine d'avoir les 30 pays de
l'alliance atlantique unis avec un même
message pour laisser la porte ouverte à
l'otan à l'ukraine c'est assez nouveau
on a l'habitude de parler la désunion
européenne non en termes de politique
étrangère là on a un front uni alors
évidemment après les discussions sur les
sanctions en cas d'attaqué russe en
ukraine les discussions sont beaucoup
plus compliqué donc c'était ça le
problème avec les allemands notamment
avec ce gazoduc dont vous parlez
virginie oui le problème de l'allemagne
c'est surtout que son propre
gouvernement est divisé il est tout
nouveau il n'a même pas trois mois et on
a les verts qui tiennent le ministère
des affaires étrangères qui sont plutôt
sur une position très ferme très durs
envers la russie et les sociaux
démocrates du chancelier olaf scholz qui
sont plus souples on va dire est que le
kremlin est plus dans les attitudes de
dialogue de compréhension vis-à-vis de
la russie enfin les verts qui sont quand
même aussi totalement opposé à la
livraison d'armes notamment c'est un des
leurs fondamentaux enfin en allemagne en
général l'opinion publique mais les
verts en particulier enfin s'interdisent
de livrer des armes et même sont très
réticents à envoyer des soldats
allemands sur des terrains extérieurs il
dit emmanuel macron qui s'exprimait tout
à l'heure en ukraine avoir reçu des
gages de la part de vladimir poutine
pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'escaladé
supplémentaires est ce qu'on peut croire
le président russe prendre question en
tout cas en tout cas c'est ce que
prétend emmanuel macron et on a entendu
dire poutine que oui il allait continuer
le dialogue est ce que pour autant il
exclut les autres options les autres
options c'est vraiment très difficile à
dire mais effectivement on vous l'avait
dit en catalogue pour l'instant il n'ya
pas escalade on a on n'est pas encore
dans la désescalade on est juste dans
l'arrêt de l'escaladé pour le moment il
ya eu un petit problème diplomatique
aujourd'hui entre justement l'elysée et
le kremlin parce que l'elysée dit
justement qu'il y avait eu un accord sur
une désescalade militaire de la part de
la russie et les russes cet après midi
un communiqué en disant pas du tout on
n'apprenait pas tombés d'accord
là-dessus il n'y a pas eu de
communication officielle donc c'était un
petit peu vous pour remettre aussi la
france à sa place je crois donc faut
rester prudent sur ces permis est-ce que
vladimir foot poutine de finalement avec
tout ce ballet diplomatique il n'essaye
pas de gagner du temps
justement sur le terrain pour mettre son
dispositif militaire en place
je sais pas si c'est lui qui essaie de
gagner du temps c'est surtout les au
port hope et un j'ai l'impression qu'ils
pour le moment et c'est de gagner du
temps pour justement éviter la guerre
vladimir poutine lui a posé ses
conditions quand même depuis maintenant
c'était en décembre au plus tard il a
dit ce qu'ils voulaient a priori c'était
que l'ukraine n'adhère pas à l'otan
voilà une de ces conditions essentielles
c'est en train ils essaient de faire
pression de continuer à faire pression
pour autant est ce qu'il est ce qu'il
essaye d'avancer ses pions pendant ce
temps s'est pas hissé sa condition et en
même temps deux pour les occidentaux
sont fermes la tuant ils vont rien
lâcher sur ce point on a du moins mal à
voir une issue ce qui est en train de se
passer j'admire petite amie des
exigences très très hot il est évident
qu'il attendait une division de la part
des européens elles ne viennent pas là
il a quand même depuis trois mois cent
mille hommes à la frontière qui sont
dans le froid dans la neige dans la boue
cette pas tenable sur le très long terme
mais là où je parlais à une source
militaire française cet après midi qui
me disait que dans cinq six jours
militairement la russie sera prête à la
guerre donc le temps est compté on a une
petite fenêtre diplomatique je pense que
c'est pour ça qu'on a autant d'allers
retours entre les capitales on sait que
cette série c'est crucial en dehors de
cette guerre militaire sur le terrain
disons aux guerres classiques avec des
hommes qui sont sur le terrain il ya
aussi une autre guerre qui est en train
de f1 qui est menée maintenant depuis
plusieurs mois une guerre de
désinformation une si belle des
cyberattaques en permanence des russes
attaque essai de démoraliser la
population ukrainienne ya par exemple
des fausses alertes à la bombe dans des
collèges des groupes de désinformation
sur alors c'est pas whatsapp lui c'est
plutôt signal ou télégramme des
cyberattaques assez assez particulière
pour essayer de créer un climat un peu
défaitiste et ça c'est un aspect qui
continue certainement en tout cas se
produire même si il n'ya pas d'invasion
à proprement parler pour le moment et
quel est l'état d'esprit de la
population ukrainienne on a le sentiment
qu'en en ukraine au contraire on essaye
de calmer le jeu depuis le début c'est
le message des autorités officielles de
dire surtout pas de panique on reste
tranquille je pense que les ukrainiens
sont habitués comme à ce climat
conflictuelles on va dire tout parce que
la guerre elle se poursuit finalement à
l'est de l'ukraine de piste depuis
plusieurs années je pense qu'il ya quand
même des inquiétudes clairement la
population de la part des autorités on
sait pas pour rien qu'ils n'utilisent
invite autant de dirigeants occidentaux
mais il garde un certain calme qui est
sa devise qui a été salué lors par
emmanuel macron en disant je félicite le
président une skis pour son zen et en
même temps après c'est ce que disait
tout à l'heure notre envoyé spécial au
james entrée qui en uc réalisé dans la
presse dans les médias on explique
comment
préparer enfin préparer son appartement
rapidement comment fuir part où fuir si
jamais le cas se présentait donc il ya
quand même une préparation à la
effectivement à une confrontation
militaire et washington est très
alarmiste depuis le début les états unis
est ce qu'ils jettent de l'huile sur le
feu sur ce dossier ukrainien alors je
pense que ce cas beaucoup là beaucoup
l'accusent oui je pense que c'est la
stratégie de joe biden justement
d'alerter l'ensemble des alliés pour
justement avoir ce front commun dont
parlait précédemment pour dire que les
enjeux sont très importants et que les
états unis sont présents sont là qui ne
lâche pas l'europe même si je pense que
joe biden aurait aimé passer à autre
chose notamment après le retrait
d'afghanistan l'été dernier il a marre
est passé à une confrontation que direct
avec la chine la ramenant sa l'attention
repart vers l'europe oui et puis en même
temps c'est asymétrique c'est-à-dire qu
effectivement il fait des déclarations
un petit peu un peu tonitruante mais il
a quand même à temps à perdre que ça
peut-être en tout cas si l'enjeu est
moins important pour lui que pour les
européens est que pour vladimir poutine
donc il a tout intérêt à ce que la crise
soit résolue assez rapidement bientôt
donc des discussions à nouveau au format
normandie sur sur cette crise
ukrainienne qu'est ce qu'on peut en
attendre concrètement concrètement que
le dialogue continue que des portes
continue d'être ouverte surtout que le
dialogue ne s'arrête pas je pense que
c'est la priorité pour les européens
aujourd'hui pour les ukrainiens et pour
la 10 mai pour poutine c'est compliqué
de le dire personne ne sait vraiment ce
qu'il va faire même lui j'ai un doute
sur ses sur sa propre connaissance de
ses intentions un dernier mot peut-être
qu'une des options aussi dont enfin
qu'on a évoqué alors emmanuel macron a
dit ne pas avoir utilisé le no c'est
aussi la finlandisation la piste de la
finlandisation qui est une forme de une
sorte de
souveraineté un petit peu limité une
sorte de neutralité avec un alignement
de la politique
étrangère à la russie ou en tout cas une
neutralité par rapport à la russie et
une indépendance intérieur c'était le
format enfin c'était le système est en
tout cas connu à la finlande après la
deuxième guerre mondiale et c'est
quelque chose qui est en train de se
discuter c'est à dire avec donc une
ukraine qui potentiellement n'entrerez
pas dans l'otan mais qui pourrait
potentiellement rentrée en s'interdisant
de critiquer la russie et en s'alignant
sur sa politique étrangère donc voilà ça
c'est peut-être aussi des choses qui
sont en lice mais on suivra ça de très
près merci beaucoup virginie herz merci
corentin peinard guère d'avoir été ici
ce soir pour on va plus loin place à
présent dans paris